so today is really a history shifting
day for the Los Angeles Lakers and I
think any time you have a landmark event
where you have an opportunity to
introduce the most dominant young
basketball player in the world as a
member of a Los Angeles Lakers you have
a lot of people to thank seems like
we've been talking about you coming here
for months and months now how relieved
are you that it is finally over and what
was the most difficult part of this
process for you thank you I think the
most difficult part for me was just not
knowing you know the unknown you know it
was whether you know your traded or
whether now go back to New Orleans so I
think the unknown was just the most
difficult for me and then when you know
it was announced that I was being traded
I won't say was a sign of relief who was
just you know you know something that
you know that I thought about for a long
time you know obviously it was tough for
me to you know leave the city I've been
playing for for seven years but now I
think it was know best for me and it was
my time but when you know when I found
out being traded to the Lakers they were
I realized it was an unbelievable
opportunity for me to be here a
wonderful organization and then I get to
play alongside you know LeBron and
obviously now the players that we have
now but back then before it was really
just LeBron here and so you know they
get opportunity to do that you know and
come here and play for organization
that's all about winning
oh forget winning winning championships
you know and that's the only goal I
think that was the biggest thing for me
just the relief there of not you know
not knowing that unknown anymore and
knowing where I was gonna be next season
I'm just wondering how you think that
playing alongside LeBron on offense and
defense is going to impact your game
just having somebody that's on along
that same level of skill and then I also
wondered if coach Vogel if you could
address that as well
the things you're doing the floor pretty
amazing
now you see it on on you know TV and
you're a family you're a friend of the
game you watch it a lot and I never have
really had a chance to experience you
know playing alongside him 2012 Olympics
I didn't play as much I would like to
tell God just wave it out and then you
know we had a little bit of time doing
all-star games but to get a full season
and just to see the things that he's
able to do pass who talks well
defensively know he's a great leader you
know so I'm excited to you know you get
a lot of that you know this season and
just go from there
with all the moves that have happened
since you've been traded to the Lakers
you know it seems like the league it's
an arms race how do you stack up your
team against what everything's happening
to League right now they're gonna be fun
it's gonna be fun for sure you know I'm
excited about it I think we his has a
grown I think it's better all the
players you know teaming up and kind of
spread spreading that talent throughout
the league it's gonna be a fun season no
I like our Ross are like you know every
play that we have you know from one
through 15 what 14 1 through 14 so I'm
excited about it and you know I'll put
our roster get up against anybody I feel
like that you know in a seven-game
series that will come out victorious a
anthony and frank only owns like ESPN
was wondering uh the lakers made sure to
keep cow Kuzma and not trade him in that
package for you is wondering what do you
see in kyle Koosman do you think he can
kind of be that third guy with you and
LeBron and Frank I was wondering what
have you seen in Kuzma this summer
unbelievable player a young player who
is steadily growing always working on
his craft you know anytime we I played
against him it was always great battles
you can shoot it he stretch the floor
you can put it down you can finish got
some post moves so
not very sorry about man long saw him
Anthony what went in to the decision to
waive your trade kicker obviously
anytime you able to acquire a player
like Kauai I think you got to do almost
everything to you know get a guy like
that I didn't work out for us but you
know I still wanted to make sure I did
whatever to help the team and you know
that four million was to you know you
know add more money to a player's
contract that they wanted or you know
get another guy you know them for all
means you know I was going to do that
you know and I think we did a great job
of using that you know throughout the
entire teen scene cuz it got some
attention you knelt on Instagram last
night you talked tickets through
thinking you're gonna wear number 23
this year and now you're wearing number
three no yeah that was pretty hurtful to
be on it out it they send me a listing
over and I didn't know what that she
would none of them looked right so when
I was like 2k like Paul had no personal
money but obviously you know we have
rules and you know the rule is I think
about March whatever the 15th and
something like that that you have to
make a request to change the number so
it is what it is but the first number
that I have a war was number three and I
put another picture on Instagram today
of me wearing that number when I was
like in seventh grade so when I saw the
number was available kind of just wanted
to take it all the way back so I first
started and put that number back on so
those of us on the TV and radio side we
we talked a lot about the player
empowerment era do you have a sense of
where your role is now in this decision
this idea of player empowerment deciding
your own destiny I just wanted to take
control of my career no there was always
you know people kind of telling me no we
need to do this we need to do that
you need to do this and I just kind of
like go with it you know I was you know
young and I was like okay you know I
feel like this person has the best
interest for me whatever
and then as I start getting older it's
talking more experiencing like I don't
want to do that you know I want to do it
this way
and as long as I can you know sleep at
night you know and live with the
decision that I made and you know I'm
happy and I don't really care what no
one else thinks you know I have a great
team around me who I can talk to about
you know things that's going on and they
gave me great advice and at the end of
day you know I live with this city not
me I was wondering your teammates again
with DeMarcus Cousins and he was saying
the other day that you guys never wanted
that to end when you did get to play
together what was it what did you learn
about him being his teammate the last
time you were obviously before and he
came to New Orleans
I knew him off the floor you know very
well then on the floor you know all the
media attention he got I've been you
know emotional I didn't I really see
that you know me and him we're really
close and you know I kind of told him
before like you know we when we got one
goal you know so I kind of he understood
you know and I think you know when you
know you in a situation like this
obviously last year I mean it was rarely
talked about him being emotional and
when you come to another situation like
this it's not gonna happen thing is
gonna be a problem at all because we
have one goal and that's to win and my
love playing with DeMarcus I'll
obviously we didn't want it to end but
actually he had to move on and it was
best for him and his family and now we
got the opportunity to you know reunite
in a great situation so I'm excited
about that
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with wheat report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content